my friend samantha jones even pulled my
diaphragm out with her bare hand because
it got stuck it was really stuck like
she was up in there for like a minute
samantha jones is back well
sort of excuse me but do i know you
of course actress kim catrell made it
clear she will not be returning to the
sex in the city revival series and just
like that as her beloved character who's
currently living in london after having
a falling out with carrie
wait
have you spoken to her
no
neither has charlotte
i mean we texted and called but we never
heard back but in episode five samantha
is back in the script
now proceed with caution because there
are spoilers ahead honey
i gotta go it all starts when carrie
gets hip surgery
the fashionista takes her post-op meds
which make her get candid about a vivid
and intimate memory with her old friend
which she shares on her podcast i
remember this time
that my friend samantha jones even
pulled my diaphragm out with her bare
hand because it got stuck
boundaries carried
i'm saying it was
really stuck like she was up in there
for like a minute charlotte who's nearby
helping nurse carrie back to health
becomes concerned that samantha might be
upset by carrie's story
so the blonde beauty decides to reach
out via text and to her surprise the
power publicist responds
yep that right there is samantha in true
samantha fashion writing that she's not
bothered by the story being made public
in fact she writes quote i love that
your vagina is getting airtime i think
what's wonderful is that we have a
writer and actors who love that
character who love telling stories and
being in
situations and environments with
samantha
and we're really lucky we have those
memories and that experience
the nods to samantha throughout the
series so far come as no surprise it's
something the series showrunner michael
patrick king talked to e.t about at the
show's new york premiere
we conceived in just like that with just
carrie miranda and charlotte to start we
knew kim wasn't going to do the series
because she had for her reasons finished
playing samantha we did everything we
could to honor samantha who we love the
character and we know the fans love
no one could be another samantha but
samantha isn't the only friend carrie
has struggles with this season
here let me spark this up while napping
post surgery she wakes up to find
miranda getting drunk during the day and
hooking up with her boss jay diaz which
makes miranda not too helpful amid
carrie's recovery maybe charlotte was
right maybe you do have a drinking
problem
i don't have a drinking problem
i just got a little carried away
you are married and you just had sex in
my kitchen
i'm unhappy
i'm unhappy
okay
i'm trapped
i hate my marriage
i hate it
i hate my life i i hate it but it seems
like miranda is seeing the mistakes
she's making and decides to pour her
demons down the drain literally
those mistakes are something actress
cynthia nixon spoke to e.t about earlier
this month we didn't come back to be
boring we didn't come back to do stuff
that we've already done we came back to
to throw these characters into new
situations and let them
you know follow their hearts sometimes
you know mistake you know sometimes
making mistakes sometimes on the right
path
um and you know
i don't know
you didn't like us because we were
boring the first time you liked us
because we took chances and that's what
we're doing and you know stick around
there's a lot to come
[Music]
you